Hey
in the videos on Bulger Latin and romance.
Now you learned about number in gender.
The now Lupo is masculine.
Gus says, Feminine
Lopez, masculine, plural,
and Cassie's feminine, plural. You
also found out about agreement.
The article Elu matches the
masculine singular noun in Isla loop,
but the feminine plural
Alaska says that covers the
basics of adjectives to Bonu.
Good has forums like Bono, Bono, Barney,
and Barney to match the noun.
It describes Benet dare born the looper.
Bonu. An English adjectives
are said before the noun,
but most romance adjectives
follow the noun. You dare delay,
delay,
delay.
Some adjectives have four forms like
Bonu with typical masculine and feminine
endings. Others just have
two forms, a singular
in a lake and the plural like UCI lays
plurals work just like noun plurals.
So there's the expected
eastwest split bonding.
He Day in the East Bonus Das in the West.
He Day in the east.
Eds with delays in the west.
Determiners also work
a lot like adjectives.
These include the definite
and indefinite articles there.
The demonstrative is for this and that
you stay there and the possessives
like male my to your nose through our
May. I you Dan, most right there
question words began with quo like the
pronouns queen and Queen or the adverb
Quando.
Yeah,
the determiner.
Wiley for which agrees with,
it's now widely there.
See,
pay attention to the order of adjectives
and other agreeing words within a noun
phrase. As mentioned,
adjectives tend to follow them.
A few very common adjectives
like bono precede the noun.
Okay.
On the left most side we find determiners
like articles or possessive or even
both articles and possessives.
Mab wanting you death.
[inaudible]
right.
Classical Latin had endings for
comparative adjectives like easier and
superlatives,
like easiest.
The modern languages used phrases with
more instead with mice or pluse for more
[inaudible]
Louis [inaudible]
for easier.
Then it's mice Faqih liquid
or blue.
Spiky liquefy.
Yeah.
The superlative is most
often illuma is fuck you lady
or [inaudible] Bay.
Although the old ending is
CMO has survived for emphasis,
meaning really easy.
A small set of adjectives.
Stubbornly retain their old
Latin comparative forums,
notably Bonu good meliore better,
but best is normally
Illuma, Yoda, and optimal.
Once best now means really good or great.
Okay.
We'll spend a few moments on adverbs.
Adverbs include words like Bennet,
well in contact banner sings well
and 80 yesterday in Eddie can tie
languages can also form adverbs
productively out of adjectives.
When Western romance
languages attached the ending
maintain to a feminine adjective.
It's already made adverb collateral,
clear Colada maintain comes to
me clearly in Portuguese, French,
Italian, and so on. Romanian
didn't share in this innovation.
There's so much more to share,
but this quick tour has opened the door
to adjectives and adverbs in the romance
languages.